sorry for that okay
so i started the beginning here thanks
for the invitation and i wanted to let
you know that i wanted to attend in
person but due to problem with my
vaccinations that status it was not
possible
anyway so i will report about joint work
with felipe cook from plares so i have
worked on that for several years already
and it started when pierre was a postdoc
in berlin
so if you look at the title you may
think that there's not so much relation
with the topic of the workshop but
this is actually not the case so there
are
two connections one thing is that what
i'm going to tell you about is very
closely related to symmetries so the
action of the unitary group will be very
very important
also
i think a main topic of this workshop is
optimization on the symmetry and there
is this
null this non-commutative optimization
of the nullcomb problem that cole franks
talked about in the first talk of the
workshop and i have some hope that we
can progress along these lines with the
methods that are used
in my current work right
right because if you want to optimize a
function actually you you try to find a
zero of the gradient right and the
gradient is a system of equations
okay
so
let me start
and by the way i mean if there are
questions feel free to interrupt me i
don't have too many slides so i think it
should be able to accommodate
so it's about solving system of
equations and i restrict to polynomial
equations so what i have i have a system
of n homogeneous polynomial equations
in n variables the degrees are d1 d2 up
to dn
i want to compute the solutions because
it everything homogeneous it's nice to
think of solutions in complex projective
space
of course this question is it has been
intensely studied for i mean 400 years
maybe and it's not possible that i
summarize all the contributions here
so what is very well known is that there
are some algebraic algorithms symbolic
computation which can compute all the
solutions by the zoo theorem we know the
number of solutions typically is product
of the degrees many they can be computed
with the number of arithmetic operations
which is
roughly d to the constant time n and by
small d
i denote the maximum of two degrees
so many people contributed to that
result i just named a few
uh and i apologize
for those people that are not mentioned
here
this problem has been intensely studied
okay but d to the end is very big right
if you think of n as big so the question
is can we do better
can we do better if we just want to
compute one or a few solutions i mean if
you want to compute all of them d to the
n that cannot be done much but if you
just want to have one solution maybe we
can do better
and in fact this is possible
but think now that
that the polynomials the input
polynomials are somewhat are
sufficiently generic
so i don't want to address the situation
when the polynomials are somehow
degenerate where there are singularities
or not okay so this i'm not talk about
the algebraic algorithms can handle
these situations but our algorithms
can't
so on the the magic word here is
numerical homotopic continuation so
these algorithms are capable of doing
this right
and here is a little advertisement so
there is an impressive software by my
former student paul bryding and sasha
team both were both in berlin
they
implemented
quite impressive software that works
very very well so if you have time or if
you like doing it
check it out julia homie copy okay just
practice
okay
so
homotopic continuation algorithms this
algorithm have been known for
a long time right
so actually it's interesting that gauss
when he proved the fundamental theorem
of algebra his idea behind was homotopic
continuation so it's very old
but the investigation of the complexity
of homotopic continuation is much
younger and it was investigated in
detail by a series of work by shubin
smale in the 90s
so there is this small 17's problem that
they
smell stated and
now it's sold and what does it say
um can a zero of n complex polynomial
equations in n unknowns be found
approximately on the average
in polynomial time with the uniform
algorithm okay there are a couple of
terms here they're undefined so for
instance average what is average mean
so
it means somehow we maybe a small asks
about average complexity so we assume
there is some distribution on the input
polynomials and what he meant here was
the
uh
that the polynomials are gaussians
with the gaussian that is unitary
invariant so this is exactly
distribution that popped up in kohl's
talk and i think he referred to it as
i mean the different names cost on
distribution bombay eval distribution
it's well known in physics as well okay
and what does it mean approximately
okay there is no epsilon here so
this is quite clever so smale came up
with the he defined the notion of
approximate solution and it means
that
you are so close to a solution that when
you run a newton iteration you
immediately converge quadratically and
you can reach arbitrary precision very
very fast so this is precisely defined
so this question by smail was completely
solved by pierre leres in 2017
based on work by schupsmail
piltranompardo and myself with felipe
cooker
and not only that he showed average
polynomial time he
essentially obtained pirae in a in a
paper later
he obtained an essentially optimal
result for the dense system dense by
dense i mean
that the polynomials have all
coefficients right and what he had
arrived he had
quasi linear expected cost so the the
expected number of operations is
capital n
times some polynomial in n and d and
capital n is the input size this is
in the arithmetic model is the number of
coefficients okay input size in the
dense model and you see this is capital
n is the time you need to read the input
there is not much you can improve here
okay so
so what
okay but the problem with this result
it's a nice result but how meaningful is
the dense model
as i said already in the dense
representation this capital n is this
sum of binomial coefficients usually
it's a huge number okay but if you have
a problem of interest coming from
practice it's usually structured in some
sense
so actually these structured system they
lie in a set of measure zero in the
input space of all polynomials and the
previous result is meaningless for that
case right it doesn't tell us anything
so
i mean the goal is to say something that
goes beyond the dense setting okay the
dance setting was only the first step
towards understanding the problem
okay
right so
um
so okay
good
so but what does it mean structured
there are many ways to define this i
mean something that immediately comes to
mind is to think of sparse systems so
you prescribe to support so the
polynomials that can occur
so there is a stream of work by gregorio
malachovic
okay who obtained very interesting
results
but nothing conclusive
here
i only assume or we only assume that the
polynomials are given by a black box so
very weak assumption that is very common
in optimization okay the polynomials are
given by some evaluation routine we
don't even need to know what happens so
actually i believe i usually think of
the polynomials given by an arithmetic
circuit but this is actually not even
needed it's a black box model
okay
so
the problems
that we have i mean that we have to
overcome somehow is that
because we want to
okay we want to
we prove theorems we need to certify
step sizes for these homotopies we will
need to have compute higher derivatives
of the functions given by a black box so
this is some difficulty
and some feature of our method is that
we compute the step sizes by random
sampling so
okay and our algorithm will be
randomized it fails we control the error
probably so this is just a 10 000 feet
view of our algorithm explaining some
features
peter i have a question sure
in this model do you get charged
for the
number of bits that you write when
you're accessing the blackboard this is
the model of if you want real number
model where i count the arithmetic
operations right but you can you can you
can input to this black box any real
number that's
right or whatever right but okay but
since we control in every step condition
i think it is not a problem i mean we
control errors so we can truncate so i
don't think it causes a problem
right okay
so
so the result i mean we have this
algorithm we call it blacksbox solve
okay it's a monte carlo algorithm and
has the following specification
so we have some confidence the input is
some confidence parameter epsilon
and the system capital f
is capital f the components are small f1
up to fn
and i assume that each fi is given by a
black box
and with the promise that the black box
computes a homogeneous polynomial of
degree d i in m plus one variables and i
assume here that the zero set of my
system is regular no singularities okay
this is also a promise if you want
and under these assumptions
the algorithm black box solve it
terminates almost surely
it's a randomized algorithm right and it
computes an approximate zero in the
sense of small
with probability at least one minus
epsilon so this is a statement
this statement by itself is maybe not
too interesting because what's the
running time okay how fast is it okay
let's talk about the running time
and in order to make this statement
about the running time i need to
introduce some
parameters that relate somehow to the
condition of our input to the numerical
condition
so the most important parameter here is
the gamma parameter very important here
so what is this gamma
okay i try to explain it but
so let's assume i have a single
polynomial f one homogeneous polynomial
and the point that let's say this rep
has i think of a representative set
and this gamma is this funny looking
quantity
it looks what this is it looks a little
bit complicated
so what we have here like this guy here
is the case or the derivative of f
at that so it's a multi-linear map or a
symmetric tensor if you want and we take
the frobenius norm
okay then we multiply with the norm of
the inverse of f is actually the
gradient if you want
then we take this funny root and the
supremum
okay so whatever it looks complicated
but to
give you a feeling of it
think of
the contribution to this
quantity for k equals two
so for k equals two i have here the
second order derivative and then if you
look at this very closely
and you know a little bit of
differential geometry then you know that
this quantity for k equals 2 upper
bounds the curvature of the zero set of
f so f has a zero set it's a hyper
surface
he has a curvature
given by the second fundamental form and
its norm is upper bounded by this okay
so this is captured by the gamma but the
gamma captures more things that are
maybe not so easy to understand
okay
so this definition goes back to steve
smale
who defined a similar quantity for
systems so now i have my capital f is
actually a system
okay typically zero set is now not a
hypersurface but a finite set of points
and he proved a very important result in
86 this is the gamma theorem i should
have highlighted it in blue
this is the gamma theorem and this
explains the meaning of this gamma
notion the meaning is one over the gamma
up to a constant
is the radius of quadratic conversions
for newton iteration so one one needs to
define what this neutral iteration in
this setting because it's not the
euclidean setting i work on complex
projective space but this is rather a
minor thing and i don't want to enter it
okay so this this is uh when you are
yeah
close to a zero less than one over gamma
times the constant then you know you
have these immediate conversions so this
is very important
so in pierre there is he came
he defined this quantity this is related
to it now i'm back
to a single polynomial
okay the zero set is a hypersurface is a
projective hyphen service so it's
compact
so what we do now we for at each point
zeta in this hyper surface we have this
gamma or gamma square and then we
average this with respect to the uniform
distribution
and this we call capital gamma of f
does it also need to assume that your
system is just regular as well like all
the polymers are regular that's right
right this is right this is only if the
polynomial system if
right
if i have a singular
zero the gamma is infinity
okay
so this is only for simple i should have
said this only applies to simple zeros
or everything i'm telling you is for
single is for simple zeros okay
okay this was raphael oliveira right
okay
so
so to each polynomial we have now
assigned this quantity gamma of f comma
small f and if i have a system capital f
i just combine these numbers into a
single one for instance this way
but i can also take the maximum of the
gammas that's not important okay so
somehow each system has now a gamma
which somehow gives a measure of a new
okay numerical quality if you want
okay
now next feature is
unitary invariance so this is a very
important feature
actually it enters in two ways on the
one hand it enters in the description of
the algorithms i will explain explain
that
on the other hand it also enters in the
probabilistic analysis
okay
so i have the unitary group here
it acts on the space of homogeneous
polynomials of degree d in m plus bond
variables just by linear transformation
so you think of orthogonal coordinate
transformation
okay
so
i think we know everybody knows that
it's also in quantum
physics
or is everywhere
but now since i'm dealing with systems
of polynomials my group acting is a
product of unitary groups i denote it
with this calligraphic u so
right and the action is this i have here
a system of
polynomials and here a group element u 1
up to u n
and i act individually individually on
these polynomials right so if you think
of
maybe think of two
ellipse just to have something concrete
in mind then i can rotate them
individually right so typically the
relative position of the two ellipses
will be good right
because i'm allowed to rotate
so one observation is this
goes well with this black box model
because if i have a black box for f i
i easily get a black box for the
composition right there's no problem
first i have to compute the linear
transformation it's cheap
and then i apply the black box
okay
so on the probabilistic analysis that i
will tell you applies to structured
settings actually to all structure
settings that respect this unitarian
variance
okay
and
what we what i will do i have this
algorithm blackbox off
and what i will bound is the expected
running time of the algorithm over an
orbit
of this group action
this is what i do right this is this is
these are the rules of our game
okay so here is the precise statement
probabilistic analysis of black box
solve
so besides this gamma capital f which
captures numerical quantity i have
another parameter which is easy to
understand this is the l of f like
length
so this is the number of arithmetic
operations sufficient to evaluate f
right so if i think of f given by a
straight line program it's the usual
algebraic complexity measure
or otherwise if you are in black box
setting general you just count the
number of times you call the black box
okay so theorem one
let's assume
the input capital f is square free means
all the polynomials f i are square free
right so i have this
then i pick a uniformly random group
element
and i give to my algorithm black box
solve f transport f transformed u right
so you have this f two ellipses if you
want rotate them randomly and this is
the input and epsilon is also an input
then the algorithm black box off
on average over the orbit
performs at most that many operation
so what is this bound
you see
it's quite small
so
l
enters linearly i have l of f
times gamma f log comma f plus log one
over epsilon times something polynomial
in n and d
actually of small degree
okay i think that's a really good bound
and we can even this is now details not
so important we can even boost it
we can even boost it with respect to the
confidence and we can replace this log
epsilon by log log one over epsilon okay
so it's um
this is the result
um and
okay consequences now this this gives an
average over the orbit
we can apply it to any probability
distribution of input polynomials any
distribution that is unitary invariant
and what we get this is an almost
immediate consequence but let me state
it anyway
right so then i get for a random input f
the expected number operation is at most
at
and now what enters here is this capital
gamma is just will be the average of
this comma f
basically f square
okay with respect to our unitary
invariant ensemble and capital l is just
an upper bound on l of f
okay
so this is very general
but
the question no i have a question sure
is l f invariant under the unitary or
it's not invariant not quite it well if
you would only count the multiplications
non-scalar complexity then it would be
invariant otherwise you have to spend a
little bit of reparations for doing
these linear operations okay but this is
just n cube which is very little
compared to you know
the complexity that we face here
so imagine in what sense are you gaining
by transforming to a random by a random
unitary if it's the same
if the algorithm depends only on the
yeah
yeah but we okay we gain various things
think of
intersecting two curves
right so these two curves maybe ellipses
can be in bad position they may be
tangents right
but if you'd make this a random rotation
you bring them in good position so that
then it will be very transverse versus
the intersection so this is for instance
this is one advantage of that okay right
yeah
okay
okay so to understand the i mean to
gauge the quality of this result there
is of course the question what is this
capital gamma how small it is
okay and this depends
on the class of polynomial systems that
we study
so i mean we took us some time to come
up with a model where we can actually
actually prove something and then we
realized there is this beautiful model
of algebraic branching programs coming
from algebraic complexity theory and
this is what we consider and i will tell
you in a moment what it is
so we look at algebraic branching
programs this class is unitary invariant
by definition all the members of the
class have small evaluation complexity
we will see we have a
natural
unitary invariant gaussian distribution
and we manage to bound the gamma in this
case so this is in a nutshell what we
did more details will come
okay
right
so
i don't know questions so far
for
anything
okay
so then let me explain
i will use the most part of my talk just
for stay motivating and stating the
result but i will also have some time
for explaining what is behind the
algorithm algebraic branching programs
right here i have another question yes
so
why why is the square freeness uh
assumed like why is it necessary there
before you repeat that there was some
acoustic problem can you repeat the
question please why is the
are ready
can you hear me now yeah now perfect oh
okay um what is the
why is the assumption on the square
freeness of your of your polynomials
like in in your first theorem or do you
have another one where you remove that
assumption yeah it's a little bit
okay the square freeness
good
this square freeness okay maybe i don't
have to go there
well
for instance it will guarantee that
almost surely
my systems in the orbit um
will have um
and you say
uh will it will be um
regular i mean what i need what i need
that all these
things are regular i mean
intersections the gamma so it guarantees
among other things that the gamma
typically we find it but it guarantees
more i mean it's in the technical
analysis
so if you don't have square free then
you have singularities
right
so if for instance if you have g's f is
g squared times h
then
all the zeros of g will be singular
already so you have the singular locus
have co dimension one and this is really
bad you don't want to have this
right
okay
sorry then my other question so the
regular inner theorem so is it saying
that the longest form of regular
sequence or
good yeah because no it doesn't say that
but
but i get it automatically i mean this
is a very common assumption in the
algebraic algorithms
but since i do this random rotation
almost surely it will be the case
right
that's what i said that right okay
almost surely it will be okay
did i answer the question or
uh sorry yeah i'll unless more later
okay good
yeah but these are good questions i mean
good questions right
so there is this model of algebra
algebraic branching programs which was
introduced by noam nissan in 91 he plays
an important role in algebraic
complexity theory and links very
naturally to this valiant vp and vnp
theorem that i think several of you know
so it's very well motivated and
universal model
for computing polynomials
it's also
okay gives a nice graphical way to
formalize computations but here i will
only work with matrices because it's
quite concise
so let me define the model just using
matrices
okay
so what do we have
so
i have complex matrices here
okay
and i form a linear combination with
variable z
then i get this thing
or you may view this as a matrix where
the entries
are linear forms in the variables so
this is exactly what
hiroshi mentioned in his talk i mean
this in the formulation of the edmonds
problem you have exactly these animals
right
and so what do i do
so this a i z has to formant
okay r i minus 1 times r i so i
design this
so that i can multiply all these
matrices so it makes sense i also assume
that it is cyclic r 0 is rd so this
matrix here will be a square matrix and
i can form the trace
okay
so basically what i do is iterate matrix
multiplication and then this
f of set the trace of the product of
these matrices
i consider that the polynomial computed
by the branching problem that's the
definition
so what i get is a homogeneous
polynomial of degree d
in n plus one variables
okay this is the model and then it's
very easy to check because of matrix
multiplication is associative
you can see that you can evaluate f with
that many operations what is it n times
d times r to the three by the way r this
is usually called the width the r
okay it's the maximum
format of the
matrices that enter here it's a measure
of the size of the algebraic branching
program so this is the model of
algebraic branching problems very well
studied
but now there comes something new and i
think we were the first looking this we
combined it with probability so we came
up with the notion of caution algebraic
branching programs
so we just assume that these coefficient
matrices aij here
just assume they are independent complex
standard gaussian why not right
and then the corresponding polynomial
here is a random polynomial of course
it's highly structured
and if you think if you expand it and
you look at the coefficients i mean they
are
the distribution of the coefficient is
highly non-gaussian even though this is
built up from gaussians i mean the final
distribution is something complicated
okay but what we can say is by
construction
the distribution of f is unitary
invariant
okay
and what is the support of the
distribution
well it's
okay the support is the collection of f
i can reach this way this is a
low-dimensional algebraic sub-variety of
the space of all forms and by a
dimension count you see the dimension is
at most this d times r squared times n
basically so this is very small compared
to the you know these binomial
coefficients which the capital n which
gives the dimension of the ambient space
so we are in this setting
and here is the theorem
two
okay
so
so we managed
right so for each such f
random given by a
gaussian algebraic branching problem i
compute now the expectation of the gamma
f square or actually i bound it and we
managed to prove that it is bounded by
this small quantity
d cubed and d plus n log d
right and this is technical
so you see
this bound is quite small right i think
i consider that as a very good bound is
certainly polynomial in d and n right
okay and the proof is quite technical i
will not bother you with it it's more
than 10 pages long and uses all tricks
of the trade
okay
so let's not enter that
rather uh think discuss a little more
the consequence of it
so here is the consequence
so the corollary
so assume i have a system
f1 up to fn given by independent
gaussian random algebraic branching
problems of degree at most d
right evaluation complexity at most l
then the algorithm black box solve
computes a zero with probability at
least one minus epsilon with a number of
operations on average which is this
you see this is polynomial in n b
l and log log one over epsilon
so
so
so i like to interpret this as a
right so there was male 17's question
and we can now ask
how about small 70s question
for structure system right and this is i
consider this a first step towards
answering it so it kind of confirms
confirms in this model that we study
here that typically you can very
efficiently solve such structure
structured systems right
so this is the
result
okay
other questions i mean
on the state question
yes
uh hi peter um
hi
i'm wondering uh
how important it is that you average
over the whole unitary orbit like could
you use a small perturbation
oh that's a very good question
it appears at the very last height this
is the question about the
smooth analysis
it i mean it's conceivable that this is
actually i will belief it should
also be true for smooth but uh so far
i mean we thought a little bit in
direction in that direction but not
seriously but i would think yes my
intuition is yes it should hold true as
well
it's enough to perturb a little bit
to have such a result i believe but i
cannot prove it right now
very good question thank you
peter can i ask in a different direction
do you need the full force of gaussian
randomness or would it be enough to have
a measure that has say the first uh
so-and-so many moments in common with
the goal
yeah
the advantage i mean this proof that we
do is really
technical and it's a long computation
and i mean as you know with gaussians
you can compute everything
it may be possible that if you have much
weaker assumptions maybe subduction this
maybe one can also i believe i believe
i don't believe the result
hinges on this gaussian it's just in
that case we can carry it out
right but it may be possible with
efforts and more techniques to get it
without the gaussians we can see that in
other models where people prove now
bounce in much more general
models right and before it was just
gaussian
right
good question yes
okay so how much is my time so
let me be good how much uh
um you have about 22 minutes okay good
that's good very good so then i have
time to say a little bit what is behind
i mean before so far i only stated the
results motivated so what is behind this
this paper that by pierre lares which
was in the journal of ems
uh rigid homotopic continuation
so this work that i'm presenting here is
in the way
part two of this work it's based on that
so what pierre did in his paper
he substantially improved this framework
consuming smail
okay
and let me explain a little bit uh what
is it
so
um
it's like a much more economic analysis
of the situation
so
we fix now such a system f as before
this is fixed
okay and i assume that
none of the okay the zero set of all the
f i are singularity free right
then i assign to this
capital f
what i called
the solution manifold the rigid solution
manifold this is this thing
and this
solution manifold consists of pairs
on the one hand you have a group element
u1 up to u n
it's in the product of the unitary
groups
and the point in complex projective
space and the condition is that
if you rotate capital f by the group
element
then zeta is a zero
okay so this is this is the thing
it's an incident variety
this one can show it's a manifold and uh
it's compact and
it's by construction oh okay we i have
the action of the group by on itself of
course i have the action of
okay here isn't okay sorry
there is a little mistake
when i act okay let me correct it when i
act simultaneously
okay i have a group element in the
unitary group and i transform all the f
i with the same group element this is
one action
just of u n plus one and i also have
action of u of the unitary group here
and then you is invariant on the dead
and what i wrote here is not correct so
it's
sorry i wanted to correct it
here also it must be the smaller group
sorry about that
and then
there is uh
what is maybe a little bit surprising
when you see it for the first time
it's actually so you have this new
it's a
compact sub manifold of u times p n
and so i have a uniform measure on it
and it's actually possible to
efficiently sample in this manifold
i don't want to tell you why right now
maybe at the end when if there is time
but just take it for granted that this
is possible right
that i can sample and this will
important be important for having
starting systems of the
homotopic
right so that but this is a very
important point very important
okay so now what do i do
so
uh okay
now what i'm explaining you now this is
very general and i try to draw a little
picture so i have
right
now this is uh this is another so u
is in the group u
and i i have an element u in the group
okay let me make a picture here
and
so here is u
here is p n
and i have an element u here and here is
the identity element in the group and i
connect this
by a geodesic path i you know in this
picture it's got just a straight line
but think of
connecting
okay this by any
okay smooth curve right
so and then as i said i assume okay
because okay here i have zero zeta
okay so i mean actually
this drawing is
on the one hand is my picture of the
solution variety so here is the solution
variety its elements are pairs u comma z
that can project down to u
so this is just a projection map
and what is important if i have here
let's say i have a
group element here and i look what is
above
i look at the fiber of this map maybe
called the map pi i look at the fiber
i mean if you is not in a special
position somehow
the fiber will be finite okay and
even the map the derivative of this
projection map will be locally
invertible so i can apply the in
inverse function theorem so these are
very general principles from topology if
you want the point is if
okay if
for almost all path here i can uniquely
lift this curve down here i can lift it
up to a curve here
solution variety
okay
so and maybe this is
theta zero
and here i end up with zeta one and this
will be
um
right
this will be a zero of the system i'm
actually interested in because here
the the the group element is the
identity okay so i the polynomials are
not rate rotated anymore so in a way i
have my system
i rotate
okay i have this hyper surface i rotate
it at random
i am some magic
i can compute the solution for the
rotated thing and then i do the homotopy
and rotate back to the identity arriving
at the solution
of the system so that's the
okay this is the general plan
so actually what so what i do here
okay okay now i can see i do a homotopic
continuation along the orbits
of systems okay
and the one advantage also of this is
that the dimension of this product of
unitary groups is just n cubed so it's
very small compared to the dimension of
the ambient space
right so
okay this is very general but all these
homotopic continuation algorithms rely
on that principle very general okay so
so what do i do so let's uh so what are
the features of this rigid homotopy
um
what is very important is i mean in this
thing here of course
when i i will do a computation so i will
have to discretize here somehow
okay
to follow because i will follow
this curve only approximately
okay and then the main question is
always what are the step sizes okay how
do i have to discretize
this is the
most difficult question
and what we do here in the rigid homo
top is the step sizes are computed from
small's gamma parameter so somehow from
higher order derivatives
and what i'm okay what i say here is
maybe a little bit for the experts but
people will watch videos later on so let
me say it
so
so because the way we do it we typically
get lot much larger steps than in the
original shoes mail framework in the
shoes mail firmware the step sizes were
computed from a condition number so what
they did
so and smail they they have this gamma
parameter
they estimate it from above by the d to
the three half times mu
the mu is a condition number
so the advantage of mu is it's much
easier to compute only depends on the
first order derivatives
but if we do this but this is quite
wasteful okay when it comes to analyzing
structured systems so it's really
important that we work with this guy
otherwise we couldn't arrive at these
good bounds okay
also there there is experimental work by
howard stein detail well
the
okay these are heuristics but they also
show that
higher order derivatives are relevant
for choosing the step sizes
okay
so
now more mathematics so i think this
slide is really important also for the
optimization
so i had on the on the picture before i
had this path
in the rigid solution variety here okay
here is the path
and i
now i tell you how to implement in
principle
um the numerical continuation so let's
assume i have a discretization of the
unit interval okay
you have the unit interval time steps t
0 t 1 t 2 up to t k
then to simplify notation
the group element at time t i i denote u
i
and the rotated system at time t i i
denote f i
and the idea is well it's inductive
the idea is
i mean the true zero of f i is eta i
this is the true zero
and i have an approximate zero so
that i is close to zeta i now i have to
go to the next step
the way i do it i do a newton step
a newton step with respect to the
function f i plus one so this is the
next function
okay i choose a step size that's then i
have my next function f i plus one i do
one newton step with f i plus one
starting with the previous approximation
i call the result c i plus one
and i want to choose the step size so
small
that i
this z i plus 1 that say i plus 1 is an
approximate 0 for zeta i plus 1. so this
is the plan okay of course it's quite
technical to elaborate all that
and it turns out
you right
now we apply this male gamma theorem but
there is more so in the end what we do
to define our algorithms we choose the
step size inverse proportional to some
variant of the gamma i call it gamma
twiddle
okay i define in the next slide what it
is
but the point is this
okay so this look is quite complicated
because the discretization is behind but
what is really nice is
the number of continuation steps that
are sufficient become bound by an
integral so by a quantity that is
continuous is much easier to understand
so the number of continuation steps and
this is in pierre's paper is bound is at
most a constant times the integral of
this quantity gamma twiddle along the
path
right
so
to understand then we the task is to
bound this integral once this is proof
this theorem you just have to bound this
integral so what is gamma twiddle
okay
so we call it
split gamma number and it's built up
from what
so
i already at the beginning of the talk i
told you
how to assign to each polynomial
a gamma right
and here this is just
this
and you say the l2 mean of the
individual of the gammas of the
individual polynomials but now we have
this blue quantity here
which somehow tells us
the
relative position
of these zero sets
so we intersect n hypersurfaces
and this kappa measures the relative
position so maybe no point in giving the
precise definition but just to have an
intuition
here let's assume i intersect two curves
okay
and i have an intersecting point
zeta so i have these two curves right so
here
two curves here's a curve here's a curve
here is it
then i look at the angle between the
tangents
okay let's call the angle theta
and then one over the sine of theta this
is this copper
one of the sine of theta this is what is
written here
so this is i mean what's happening
actually and then you can see the kappa
is greater than or equal one
it equals one if and only if i have
orthogonal intersection which is the
best case
it's also one can see that the kappa is
fine and if and only if i have
transversal intersection so this is the
what we're doing
right and somehow the idea is this kappa
is quite a harmless thing because
because we average over these unitary
groups this kind of this the average
of this is kind of small and it goes
away it's bloody relevant all of the
action is in the gammas
okay of course this is very hand-wavy
but
i hope
okay so now i think this is my last
slide before the open questions
uh there's one additional feature
right how do we compute this step size i
mean we have to compute this gamma this
split comma number
but which involves these gammas but the
gammas in the definite of the gamma size
have all these higher order derivatives
so how can we do that when f is given by
a black box
and the idea is this
so
let's look at the case order derivative
of a polynomial f that's here
let's say divided by k factorial and
let's call this p
so you can view it as a symmetric tensor
as or as a homogeneous polynomial as you
like
but this is just taylor this is the
degree k homogeneous part
of the shifted polynomial so you have
the polynomial f here you shift it by
that
then take homogeneous part of degree k
this is okay the taylor expansion
the degree
k contribution
okay
and
by interpolation so this is a typical
trick in algebraic complexity it's quite
easy to compute p if you have f by a
black box you can do the shift in the
black box model and then by
interpolation you get the p
you have a black box for p
now comes the following observation
i need the frobenius norm
of the case or the derivative a squared
this turns out to be
the square of the mile norm of this
polynomial p so the w here here refers
to the while norm i think it appears in
cause talk
and
this while norm is up to a constant
factor an expectation
so think of
choosing an element x uniformly at
random in the euclidean ball b in c n
plus one
choose x uniform adrenion evaluate
the polynomial p absolute value squared
it's like this
amplitude square
take the expectation so what you get up
to a constant factor is exactly this guy
okay
and
okay once you realize that then you then
you can estimate is well known by random
sampling so this is the idea
do you estimate these comma it's maybe
sounds a bit crazy but
for a practitioner but you know
theoretic meteoritis can do anything
so we actually estimate this gamma using
monte carlo random sampling and of
course there are things that you have to
prove concentration and stuff in order
to make everything rigorous but this is
the idea
okay so
open questions
there are many
okay but they only give three of course
you may
try to find other unitary invariant
ensembles of homogeneous polynomials
that you can analyze okay maybe
possible there is the question that i've
called asked smooth analysis very
interesting but challenging
but here i think it's the
the blue one is the most important
question i mean related to this workshop
so that's uh i also chose this topic
so maybe not so many people know that
so
there are in convex optimization
euclidean spaces we know there are
ethereum point methods
but interior point methods can be viewed
in the framework of newton homotopic
continuation right there's a unified
view
and you can learn about that in a paper
by renegade shoop from 92 in
mathematical programming where he
explained where they explain how to see
this how
okay instead of the self concordance you
use male's gamma theorem and it fits
together
very beautifully and it's kind of more
general
so somehow i believe that
these techniques that play a role in for
this talk they should be useful
for developing further methods for
non-commutative optimization and the
nulco membership program
okay and
i thank you for your attention
all right any questions
hi peter very nice talk um
i got a little confused during the the
proof outline
um because
it seems like
when you're
you know computing this uh
randomly rotated solution
um i thought that that's what you wanted
to do to begin with um
but i i guess it it looked like in the
proof it looked like you already had
some way to compute the randomly rotated
solution and then you you're using that
to compute it the solution is the
identity this is because i this because
i didn't explain you something actually
very important how to do this sampling
so maybe i can
if you give me one or two minutes maybe
i can explain a little bit
what we actually do how do we sample so
how is it possible
so let's see
okay
so here is uh here is an ellipse okay
and
so how do i sample a point on the
ellipse
i take
a random line
okay
and then i compute intersection points
and this can be efficiently done because
you know when you restrict to the line
you have your polynomial here is the
polynomial zero set of f1 you restrict
to the line so
this means you have like a univariate
polynomial and we know how to compute
solutions to one variable polynomial so
we can compute these zeros and we pick
one of them at the end maybe this one
okay
and then you have the other ellipse okay
maybe it's a bit
this one
also take a random line and take a
solution now you have two solutions okay
but they are not the same unfortunately
right
so um but then what you try to do is um
did i explain it correctly
um
[Music]
now you rotate back
right
now you take you take a rotation
okay sorry
that moves this thing
sorry this point
back here
okay
okay maybe my explanation is not very
clear so um let me see
okay
i think okay what sorry
i think about what i should set i should
have said this um
right sorry this is a bit incomplete and
sorry if it takes longer
what i wanted to have here
i wanted to let's say the first ellipse
is fixed and the second one is randomly
rotated okay
and then you compute a zero here
and then
then you move i mean this u is a
rotation let's say by 30 degrees and now
you move this back
okay you move this this u is moved back
to the identity so you rotate this back
and um
right
so maybe maybe call i think will be best
to explain it offline so
sorry i think i'm not very clear now
no problem i'm adding to the confusion
but
i'm sorry about that but
i think my question is really why can't
you use this to solve any polynomial uh
like just to to like why do you once you
uh
yeah i guess why do you why can you only
find roots of randomly rotated
polynomials
with this
continuation okay
so okay but you see
our algorithm
i mean this is not true
i mean
if you look at the statement
i don't need to do this random rotation
so the first okay i want to find this
slide sorry if i can the statement
here
this look at
here
so this algorithm black box solve
you only need the assumption
that
i have a regular zero set
transversal intersection then it
terminates almost surely
so it's not you see
this
unitary orbit is just for the analysis i
see i see so this is terminates almost
surely it's only for the analysis that
we have these orbits
that's actually quite an important point
actually it would look like something
really unrealistic yeah you can run this
algorithm
okay
and it will give an answer almost surely
it's just a question of the time
okay and we only make an estimate of the
time over randomly rotated inputs
okay thanks yeah i think i was just
say the confused
also were confused about that and we had
to fix it
subtle
thank you
okay
um
hey well peter thank you so much for the
wonderful talk
okay thank you you're welcome
now it's time for the coffee break i
guess
all right
so
then
bye bye